wednesday afternoon game on nbc and the
man who is uh who called the bears
uh packers game on sunday night with
mike tarico and has been calling some
games with mike tarico for notre dame
football and is in studio
uh he's a jack of all trades he he's
suddenly become the taste them hill of
of analysts
he's pro football hall of famer from nbc
sports tony dungy how are you coach
oh i'm doing well i'm laughing at that
description
i'm also laughing because you don't know
the back story to this you asked how
long chris collinsburg's been there
go for it usually what it happens every
thanksgiving
i do the thanksgiving day game with mike
tarico and then chris and al do the
sunday game chris wanted to switch
so he switched me and he's been
in pittsburgh since wednesday he now is
able to vote in pennsylvania
[Laughter]
so that could have been you so that
could have been you is what you're
saying
that could have been me i i i could have
been on a normal year i would have been
there now it's been great for me because
my in-laws lived there i've you know i
had roots in pittsburgh
but for chris collinsburg the cincinnati
bengals to be in pittsburgh for a week
is not good
well i'll tell you what it doesn't
matter i guess what your professional
playing affiliation would be just being
in pittsburgh ordering uh maybe from
primanti brothers down the street for
six days that would be a problem for me
i'll be very honest with you
well yeah i would have gained some
weight for sure i'd have been in the
motherboard
for many brothers i'd have had some good
things bob mccall's i have some old
spots
there that would have hit me up for sure
tony dungy here on the rich eisen show
there's no road map either for these
coaches
none zero no right this is amazing
i just don't know how you do this how
you you might common you keep your guys
fresh and going and then if you're john
harbaugh
i really don't think this is fair that
you don't
have practices and you're not able to go
and you're expected to go in there and
play well now john is not going to have
any excuses and he's going to expect his
team to play well but
this is tough duty and and then again
just not
knowing when you're playing right yes um
and then
and then i can't imagine what it must be
like because
you know you as a hall of fame coach can
attest right i mean
uh football coaches are the most
controlling of control freaks
of all time right you know oriented okay
you know i guess you get
routine oriented might be a a better way
to put it than control freaks but
what what no control freaks is good okay
yeah what must it be like to
sit there and know that you're gonna get
covered reports every day
right and and you have no idea what's
coming your way when somebody walks in
you got good news or bad news like i
i'd be one of those like just like send
up like give me an actual hand signal
when we walk in the room
right i don't you know i don't know when
you're going to play the game
when you're going to fly to pittsburgh
you don't know who's going to be able to
play
every day it's something different this
guy's up he'll be able to play now these
three guys won't be able to play and
this guy can play
and you might play tomorrow but no now
it's going to be
wednesday and it's not going to be a
night game now it's going to be three
o'clock in the afternoon
that drives people crazy warren sat once
said about me when i coached him and tab
but warren said
i'm the only person who can tell you
what i'll be doing a year from now on
tuesday at eight o'clock because my
coach doesn't change
this format at all oh that is phenomenal
and i kind of took that as a compliment
well i mean and and tomlin's from your
coaching tree
tony so uh how do you think he's
approaching
this week in this game all these coaches
have had to
adjust and they've had flexibility
everybody i talked to they say
flexibility
is the key you you can't do it the way
we've always done it you can't get
caught up in
in your routine you just have to adjust
you may have
a practice squad wide receiver that has
to play quarterback for you you know
what
adjust adapt and don't worry about it
and go uh it's difficult but that's the
way it is and i think that's the way
everyone's approaching it
hall of famer tony dungy nbc sports tony
dungy here
on the rich eisen show i guess the good
news if there is for
for the ravens is rg3s and uh a veteran
hand
right and somebody who uh you know we we
were just
count you know recounting in our first
segment tony um
how two years ago uh rg3 was having his
wife
film him throw footballs at palm trees
to show off his accuracy on twitter to
get a job
this is a big moment for him i i know
that there's a lot of
you know guys who he's not probably
never thrown to that it's on the field
and it's a difficult
spot but this is a huge opportunity for
him today tony and what do you think
this offense is going to look like the
same thing maybe even
a little bit better vertically with him
do you think
i think he'll do just fine if if i were
ravens fans i wouldn't be concerned
about the quarterback play
i i think robert knows the offense
um he's practiced as much as anybody
hasn't
maybe practiced well maybe he has
practice with some of the guys that are
going to end up being out there
doesn't it so they may have a good
rhythm but
i'd be concerned about my running back
uh i just read that
um mark ingram and dobbins won't play
so you got gus edwards and this is a
running team
they they need to run the ball now what
happens if something happens to gus
i don't know where you go from there and
that that's what i'd be concerned about
but i think robert griffin is going to
play just fine
tony dungy here on the rich eisen show
let's talk about the game you just
called
you know tony i know you you don't
throw these words around cavalierly but
you spoke for what i was thinking
when jamal williams just busted right up
the middle of that bear's defense
um on sunday night to put a 40 burger on
the board officially
you said the bears have given up the
bears look like they've given up and
i know you you when you say stuff like
that you understand the meaning of that
what what is the meaning of that though
for this team right now and moving
forward
tony and i was talking about that
particular game i wasn't talking about
the season or
anything else just at that moment the
bears defense we're used to seeing pride
and
you think dick butkus and brian erlacker
and mike singletary
and you know that's what i think of the
of the bears defense and that's the way
they played for most of the year
and at that particular moment it was
almost like
gosh it's all come down and rather than
these three guys make the tackle at the
three yard line
uh you know they're gonna score
eventually and
you just saw that will being broken a
little bit they'll bounce back
and and they didn't quit in the game
they came back and they played
but at that moment it was like the dam
just broke
and we we can't stop this this water
from gushing out
now but if you're a coach and you're
sitting there and you know your
your quarterback spot is an issue and
you see that on the field
and how how i know you say that they'll
bounce back but
um how how do you make that happen
how does that happen well you go and you
challenge them and you say you know what
this
this is not acceptable and uh i've i
played with some guys
joe green and and jack lambert that
i don't care if it's 50 to nothing and
we're on a 10 game losing streak
that is not gonna happen people aren't
going to walk in our end zone
and that's the mentality that they have
to get back and they've got to challenge
each other and yeah that was a tough
moment
but you know what we're better than that
and and we'll
we will bounce back and we'll show up
this week and
um what's your assessment on what if the
bears called you up and said hey tony
what do you think we should do here what
what would you say to them
i'm always one that says uh sticking
with the direction we're going
is good until you see that it just can't
work
um the bears did a lot of great things
in 2018 they did some good things last
year
uh this year it it started out okay
has gone downhill from there but they've
got a good staff they've got a good plan
here's what they've got to do get
what did we do well in 2018 we ran the
football we had jordan howard we had
tariq cohen
we ran well and that set everything else
up
and we played solid defense and we got
to take aways but we were ahead a lot
defense is fine defense is going to be
okay we've got to get them
where they're ahead sometimes and
they're defending passes and not just
having people
uh you know run run the clock down
offensively we've got to get that
mentality back we've got to get some
offensive lineman healthy
we've got to feel like we can run the
ball mitch trubisky will be okay
if they can run the football like they
did in 2018
so what montgomery i think is a good
solid back got to find another one we
got to hope to recon
comes back full speed but we've got to
get that mentality back
more than anything yeah but you as you
saw with your own two eyes and you know
deep down as well number 12 in green bay
means you got to have somebody at that
position better than okay
is is trubisky the guy do you think
that i don't know i i have not seen
enough of him
uh to to know that but he's not the
entire problem there
and and to me the problem is not so much
a quarterback but it's their running
game
i love nick fole and nick foles can do
something we saw what nick foles can do
when he
he's got the garrett blunt and uh
you know the running game that they had
there and he's got some good receivers
and
a great tight end but nick bowles
couldn't do it
uh behind that offensive line with that
running attack so
uh let let's not be so quick to throw
mitsubishi under the bus
and let's figure out where we are here i
i
want to see them get back to the
mentality of 2018
and then we'll figure out how good the
quarterback is a few minutes left here
with tony dungy pro football hall of
fame head coach and nbc sports uh
right here on the rich eisen show um you
know there's salary cap concerns there's
also concerns that maybe the kid you
drafted in the second round isn't
ready to play yet you know there's
different uh uh reasons why a coach
makes a decision
what what's your best guess why doug
peterson keeps
carson wentz in the game and keeps it
appearing to
bang his head against the same wall in
2020 here well carson wentz right now
is the best chance they have to make the
playoffs
and jalen hurts is not going to give
them
the best chance to make the playoffs if
you're saying hey we're going to look
down the road in two years from now
there's
these reps we're giving jalen hurts are
going to pay off that that's one thing
but
if you're saying we're trying to win
this thing and six and ten
may win the division and what's the best
way for me to get to six wins is it's
definitely carson wentz
now they've got some issues too uh their
offensive line
is in tatters and they're not able to
run the ball as well as they would like
and there's different receivers out
there and defensively they've got to be
a little more solid and sound
so there's a lot of things that the
eagles have to
fix if they want to win three or four
more games and be that
that playoff team but carson wentz
no question gives them the best chance
in these next five weeks
tony when was the last time you got a
call from an nfl team kicking your tires
to see if you'd be interested in
actually coaching again was the last
time that happened um
i i think it was three years ago but
i've had some calls
recently that that p that seemed more
than just a coincidence
that people are just hey how you doing
how you feel good to talk to you
and people i haven't heard from in a
long time so i think it's been about
three years but you never know
so they're not calling to ask you the
question directly but just to
just to say hi yeah what you think about
so and so do you think so-and-so would
be a good coach
and uh you know what do you think about
our team and never ask the question but
uh
you know it just seems like out of the
blue calls
because you know i you know you and i go
back and forth as to why you wound up in
the great state of minnesota um
as opposed to staying at home in
michigan and playing in the maze and
blue and you know the
the lions have a gig open there um you
know
and and you know the the situation very
well there tony
i mentioned your your colleague jim
caldwell is a possibility to come back
there
tony uh did i get lit up yeah i would do
if i were them i would bring jim
caldwell back and say
hopefully we can fix this thing but i'm
not sure what the lions are going to do
you and i rich have watched this for
years and years and years and it seems
like every time we make a little
progress
it goes back downhill i i want the lions
to be good that's my home state the team
i grew up rooting for
and i hope they make a good decision
here well i mean going forward no
i guess i i'm bringing up call well
because i got lit up
um that jim didn't beat teams that with
an over 500 record
and there was once nine men on the field
and
so on and so forth and that he didn't
have the stuff that the lions needed i
mean that's literally what i got
in terms of all of that uh uh
do you think he got a raw deal back in
the day yeah tony yeah i definitely
think he got a raw deal
because uh they they were
going in the right direction they had a
good chemistry there
just listened to mrs ford's press
conference
when she let him go that was the most
unbelievable thing i've ever heard
hey our locker room is better we've got
great direction we've won more games
than we've had over
any three year period of time in the
last 40 years
our city is better our players believe
in him but we're going in another
direction
come on that says a lot right there
but the detroit lions they're playing
the dallas cowboys in a playoff game all
they got to do is make a first down to
win the game
they throw a flag pass an appearance
have a big conference
pick the flag up dallas ends up beating
them
you know they were a playoff team
winning a playoff game should have won a
playoff game
nine and seven and someone doesn't win
and that kind of thing
and you're out of it and you don't make
the playoffs at nine and seven well we
we can't take the next step we need
somebody to
be a little more tough-hearted
hard-nosed what you got all that
and uh what were we 13 and 29
so i i think it was a raw deal i think
if jim carl will stay there they would
have been
a playoff team right now so what do you
i really believe that what do you tell
the people when they uh ask you to
assess their uh
their organization when you think they
might be kicking your tires
tony what do you say um you know i i
tell them to
really take a look at yourself
i i go back to dan rooney rich
and dan rooney and the rooney rule that
came from his name all of that really
dan rooney had a philosophy here's what
i'm going to do
we're a cold weather city we're a tough
town i'm going to hire
young communicative aggressive defensive
coaches that's what i'm looking for
and i'm gonna go out and find the best
guy and then when i hire him you know
what
i'm gonna stick with him and we're gonna
see it out so
when chuck noll goes 1-13 the first year
we're not going to panic okay that
that's our formula i picked my guy and
i'm going to stick with him
and he's the steelers have done that for
for
50 years now and that's what people need
to figure out
first of all what do i want and
i i have to set that tone and start a
direction
and then i've got to stick with it and
i've got to write it out and people may
not like it and fans might get upset
and they might think jim caldwell's not
tough enough or this or that
but you know what we're going to stick
it out and that's what i tell
people when they talk to you first of
all tell me what you want
tell me what you're looking for and then
i can help you go out and find that
what if their answer is tony dungey
let me let me go out and uh help you
find a poor man
[Laughter]
that is good all right tony thanks for
the call appreciate it we're
we're uh we're looking forward to seeing
this game today and um
i guess the next time uh chris asks you
to swap games
uh you you say no problem about it
before
he might have a hitch in his giddyup
we've got the photograph uh uh up there
it is it looks
pretty bleak i was laughing because i
said you know what
that could be me
take care of yourself tony appreciate
the call we'll chat again
always nice being with you right back at
you there's tony dungy i follow him on
twitter you should too at tony dungy pro
football hall of fame coach
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here